this is a Fox News Alert a new letter
from Republican lawmakers is demanding
that Adam Schiff testify as to his
contacts with the so-called
whistleblower more on that just ahead
but first tonight we are inching closer
and closer to truth and justice and
holding those that abuse power
accountable is I think going to take a
while
because there's probably so many of them
the dirham probe is now a full-scale
criminal investigation the Horowitz
report is expected to be out this month
I know we were also told that last month
but hopefully we'll get it this month
and a day of reckoning is on the horizon
for the deep state from the rigged
investigation into Hillary Clinton to
the dirty steel dossier to rampant
evidence of FISA abuse the media Mob
continues to ignore the real 2016
election scandal and tonight we're
learning even more about a massive media
scandal because journalists Lee Smith in
a new bombshell book hasn't covered more
evidence of a possible pay to publish
scheme involving fusion GPS and
high-profile reporters and as our own
gregg jarrett points out the so-called
whistleblower may even be implicated in
the upcoming FISA report due to his
alleged ties to John Brennan and others
now the Asteria we see over Ukraine is
just the latest chapter in what's been a
three year long campaign you guys it's
been that long to think about it three
years of constant lies smears besmirched
mints to take down a duly elected
president it is a never-ending
impeachment obsession from even before I
would argue the before is actual
election this is now about overturning
the results of the 2016 election and
overturning the will of the American
people now joining me now for a reaction
author of the book witch hunt Fox News
legal analyst Gregg Jarrett along with
former US attorney Brett Tolman and
author of the book plot against the
president journalist Lee Smith gentlemen
thank you for joining me tonight
great let me start with you with this
news about Nunez sending the letter
saying we want to have you as a witness
I find it of course troubling because
the Democrats can veto whatever it is
the Republicans want what's your take on
this it underscores the unfairness of
the
to think of it if you want to call a
witness you have to get the other side's
permission when I tried cases I didn't
have to turn to the prosecutor the
plaintiff's attorney he said may I
please call my first witness no you may
not
so you know the first witness you want
to call would be the whistleblower shift
will say denied I'd like you mr. Schiff
to testify denied
I'd like your staff that had contact
with it was denied I mean this is
anathema to fundamental fairness and due
process but it does underscore that as
well as the conflict of interest the guy
presiding over the impeachment hearing
is a fact witness himself concealing his
contact with a whistleblower who's not a
whistleblower under the law I mean this
is this is terrible you know Brett I
mean this is what's what the American
people are seeing it comes down forget
about your party on the bipartisanship
or whether you like Trump or not this is
inherently unfair the Americans are
willing to have this investigation
happen but they want to be able to trust
the outcome and of course process is the
thing that leads us to the truth so when
we hear about this and clearly I think
the Republicans want to point out this
unfairness and this request makes it
clear that there is a conflict and that
of course a ship is going to say no I'm
not going to do it and it's going to
highlight these things to the American
people is that a large part of what
matters here when it comes to how this
plays out well then this is at the heart
and I love what Gregg said because
fairness and due process are important
in this in this procedure that's going
forward and the American people aren't
seeing it and as a prosecutor I remember
being told and taught fastest way you
can throw your case out of court is if
the government loses credibility if the
government can't be trusted
well here you have the government
launching an investigation of a sitting
president based on suspicious facts
surrounding a whistleblower that appears
to be politically connected and then
they lie about their interactions with
the whistleblower for me this would be
the an absolute nightmare
I would I wouldn't want to touch this
case with a ten-foot pole but why are
they embracing it because they've lost
at every point until now and as you said
they've been focused on impeachment
since 2016 well yeah and and Lee
congratulations on your book what we're
seeing here at the same time fringing
from the Russia dossier hopes to this
there's a not just a sloppiness to
what's been done but people who expect
not to be found out but most of all they
also expect it to be you know backed up
by media they've they've worked with
media through this procedure yeah tell
us what you think because we've got so
many elements here of people it's all
hearsay and gossip and they've relied on
newspaper stories what's your take on
that element well I think what you were
saying before about this started before
the election is absolutely correct and
and in my book you know I I have
different sources who show documents and
sources show that this began in March
2016 and you saw before the election you
saw a coordination between Clinton
operatives and the press this lasted
until the election and then after the
election Clinton operatives were less
important than Obama officials this is
one of the things we're seeing now the
whistleblower issue the push to impeach
the president this is on a continuum
this has been going on for more than
three years and I think it's with all
due respect I think it's a little more
than unfairness I think I think we are
testing the patience of the American
public yes and we can I guess take marks
eight at his word that in fact he used
the word coup right Greg yeah they
already have no shame about that that
they're almost proud of it if there's
they were still on the Twitter it didn't
bother do it to to delete them and then
we've got this they the other
whistleblowers attorney so-called
whistleblower sending a cease and desist
letter to President Trump what is that
all about it's an embarrassment to the
two lawyers who wrote it I mean cease
and desist from exercising your First
Amendment right to defend yourself to
run but a false accusation and they
insanely cite three law
witness tampering the president doesn't
even know who the witness is
you can't tamper with a witness you
haven't identified obstruction of
justice nothing has been obstructed
that's for sure and finally retaliation
against a witness if you actually read
the statute the witness has to have been
killed or harmed already he hasn't been
this is ridiculous they seem to be
trying to criminalize when it comes to
the president self-defense and the
ability to engage in your defense the
ability also is president because one of
the reasons he's elected was American
people noticed that there was something
wrong there was some shenanigans that
there was maybe not the rule of law that
there was a separate kind of set of
justice for people in general
Trump's election itself was a statement
and a desire that we wanted things to be
more clear and confronted he's doing
that and as I've noted the the
impeachment the effort for impeachment
is almost necessary if we were right in
2016 that this was inevitable and now we
see historically that it was it seems to
have been expected and arranged for
quite some time gentlemen Greg Brett and
Lee thank you very much for joining me
tonight I appreciate it